[Music]
welcome back to our next episode of
what's up prof
nice to see you again walter yes it
hasn't been this long this time
no we have got a lot to say so
i'll open with a word of prayer
our heavenly father thank you very much
for bringing us together again
we ask that you guide our discussion and
let the holy spirit open our minds and
bless us with all that you do with us
in jesus name amen amen
well the title is still conspiracy
theories with a tiny little question
mark behind it
this is the third one in this little
subsection yes hopefully the last one in
this subsection then we can get on to
other topics right
correct so we were talking about
revelation chapter 11 and its effect
on the times we live in and we were
looking at the double
application the then time application of
a literal event
serving as a type for a greater event
at the close of time
now today we're going to talk about the
new
normal and i know people have heard
about the new normal but we have to
again
apply our filters and put it into
context yes
and we last looked at the destruction of
the cities
and the warning that thousands of cities
will be destroyed so this is a very
serious issue
so what is the new normal and is it an
improvement or is it a regression
now if we look at the overall picture we
know that god is going to destroy the
whole world right
yes so we have to look at what the new
normal is so we'll just play a little
video
just to get people tuned into
the idea of what the new normal is
we're going to a different place which
is a new normal a new normal a new
normal
new normal a new normal new normal
embrace the new normal the new normal
the new normal
the new normal new normal this new
normal is going to look
very very different not normal but a new
normal
the new normal new normal there will be
a new normal a new normal new normal a
new normal
the new norm a new normal this is the
new normal this is our new normal
our new normal a new normal our new
normal new normal
at the new normal for a new normal we
will transition
into the new normal this will be the new
normal
until a vaccine is developed
[Music]
it's kind of freaky folks you know when
you see that sort of stuff
you can see how long they've had this
plan in the making
you know walgreen economic forum rolling
out their whole plan to restructure the
world the great
reset that we need to combat this
terrible crisis
and the terrible state of police
brutality that we find ourselves in
everything that these people who run the
world economic forum have done
and now they're offering us their
solution which is to
basically lock everybody into a smart
prison the thing that will get us back
is the vaccine
until we have a vaccine zero tolerance
so every time we see a case we basically
pounce on it the vaccine
vaccine the vaccine the vaccine to all
seven billion people
almost every expert agrees a vaccine is
the fastest way to get our world back
you know it's so important to get not
just hundreds of millions but literally
billions of those vaccines
legislative amendments that would make
vaccinations mandatory for public school
students unless they have a medical
exemption the vaccine is the thing that
that will change things the vaccine the
vaccine on the issue of the vaccine
which you've said in the past could take
a year to 18 months will we have to wait
for a vaccine to hug our family and
friends who are outside of our bubble
you know we'll have to prepare for the
next one that
will get attention this time they're
really pushing the second wave
but this is just the beginning folks
it's not going to go away
i said that months ago this is not going
to go away they're going to release the
lock down a little bit and then they're
going to
ramp it up even more what they want to
do you know the kovi past
pass that everybody needs to have to
show their infection free
all the stuff they want to do they're
trialling it in africa now they're
calling it a
trust pass to make sure you're
vaccinated
a vaccination record payment system
is what they're talking about this is
the payment
system they want you to be scanned
retinal scanned facial scan biometric
scans
and that's how you're going to be paying
you won't need cash anymore you won't
even need your smartphone
anymore you will be paying with your
face
and of course you'll need a record of
vaccination in order to enter the store
to begin with a cashless economy where
people make purchases with their faces
a giant network of surveillance cameras
with facial recognition
helps police monitor citizens ready for
the new era of big brother
this time is super surveillance maybe
for your own good
temperature
[Music]
well this is what they're saying the new
normal will be looking like
now many are saying conspiracy theories
they mentioned the world economic forum
and the webpage of the world economic
forum i think we should have a look at
that web page
definitely especially following on the
one we did on the great reset
yes so is this a conspiracy theory or is
this a conspiracy
fact or just a thought
there are still those that pin their
hopes on
a cue character who will save the world
from this tremendous push in this
direction
is this going to happen or is this not
going to happen and of course
those who champion the idea that this
whole
new world order issue will be set aside
and normality and morality will be
coming back
they are pinning their hopes on donald
trump right yes
and this becomes very fascinating so
let's have a look at some of the other
issues that we can talk about
well firstly we have to again
just see what the jesuits have to say
i always like to know what do they have
to say
not conspiracy this is their webpage
this is
their magazine america the jesuit review
who goes first the ethics of
distributing a
covet 19 vaccine
i always like to know how these people
think
remember their whole ideology
is to follow the hierarchy
and to have no mind of your own correct
let's read what they say a persistent
anti-vaccination
minority in the united states i wonder
whether it
is a minority true it's
um when do you classify a minority
on on what basis yeah when is it a
minority so
is five million a minority
well whatever if it is a minority they
better come right right according to
these people
so a persistent anti-vaccination
minority in the united states along with
many people's
unwillingness to adopt simple measures
to prevent
spreading the virus underscores the
challenges ahead
a vaccine program is concerned with the
health of the community
and that should be important for any
christian
americans often focus on individual
health
but vaccines are essential for our
health can you see how they're
moving it in the direction of the
collective yes common good
common good for the good of the
community there we have it
common good theology who defines common
good
they do this of course particularly in
the united states there will be those
who will not
want to be vaccinated particularly if
your theology of course
is such that you consider this the
possible mark of the beast
with the nanotechnology and all of those
things
just as there are those who refuse to
wear face coverings in public and
argue for the right to be left alone
but we should remember that public
health cannot be solely concerned with
the rights of the individual
so your individual rights must be
curtailed according
to their thinking
we can respect free choice but free
choices have consequences
healthcare does not fall neatly into the
spheres of public
and private behavior the covet 19
outbreak is a reminder to americans that
health care
cannot be understood completely as a
private
good common good yes there's no such
thing as a private good
and that in solidarity with others each
of us has a responsibility to work for
a common purpose they're clever they're
trying to avoid the word
common good so that it doesn't seem so
obvious
this is a public health crisis and we
need to understand the potential vaccine
as an obligation for oneself
and for society so are they advocating
force yes and are they advocating for
the vaccine
yes both of them both of them
now it's interesting that those who are
trained at jesuit colleges
also have this mindset right obviously
but i find it fascinating that they also
have this mindset
that as far as the protests and
disruptions
are concerned they do not
definitely want to condemn it because
they are the
instigators of revolutions
and wars and calamities in the world so
let's just look at what
happened in this discussion with
the master behind the covet 19
measures jordan
thank you mr chairman dr fauci do
protest increase the spread of the virus
uh i think i can make a general
statement well half a million protesters
on june six alone i'm just asking that
number of people
does it increase the spread of the virus
crowding together particularly when
you're not wearing a mast
contributes to the spread of the virus
should we limit the protesting
i i'm not sure what you mean should how
do we
say limit the protest the government
limit the protesting
i i i don't think that's relevant to
well you just said if it increases the
spread of the virus i'm just asking
should we limit it
well i'm i'm not in a position to
determine what the government can do in
a forceful way well you make all kinds
of recommendations
you make comments on dating on baseball
and everything you can imagine i'm just
asking you you just said the
protests increased the spread i'm just
asking you should we try to limit the
protest i think i would leave that to
people who have more of an a
position to do that i can tell you
government's stopping people from going
to church dr
fauci yeah but no limit to
no limit to protest but boy you can't go
to church on sunday
what was this i don't know how many
times i can answer that i'm not going to
opine on limiting anything i'm just
going to tell you
you behind on a lot of things dr powell
yeah but i've never this is something
that directly impacts the spread of the
virus and i'm asking your
your position on the protest yeah i'm
well i'm not going to opine on limiting
anything i'm telling you what it is the
danger
and you can make your own conclusion
about that you should stay away from
crowds
no matter where the criminals stop
government
government has stopped people from going
to work
actually running their business they got
arrested you think that's okay
you know i'm not going to a point on who
gets arrested and who does not
i mean i i you get where i'm going i'm
telling you
as a public health official i say crowd
do you see the inconsistency though dr
falchi there's no inconsistency
congressman
what there's no inc so you're allowed to
protest millions of people on one day
in crowds yelling screaming but you try
to run your business you get arrested
and if you stood right outside of that
same business and protested you wouldn't
get arrested you don't see any
consistency there
i don't understand what you're asking me
as a public health official
to opine on who should get arrested or
not
that's not my position you could ask
you've advocated you've advocated for
certain businesses
you've advocated for certain businesses
to be shut down i'm just asking
you on your position on the protest and
we know the protest actually
increased the spread of the virus you've
said that
i said crowds i didn't say specifically
i didn't say
protest to anything so the protests
don't increase the spread of the virus i
didn't say that you're putting words in
my mouth no i want i would
i just want an answer to the question do
the protests increase the spread of the
virus i
i don't have any scientific evidence
that anything i can tell you that
crowds are known particularly when you
don't have a mask
to increase the acquisition and
transmission
no matter what you don't have a position
on whether the protest
increase the spread of the virus or
don't increase the spread of the virus
i'm saying that crowds wherever the
crowds are
can give you an increased probability
that there's going to be acquisition
and transmission but do you understand
americans concern
i don't think we have to say anything
it's just
interesting to see how he treads water
he doesn't want to admit that the
protests could be a problem
so he tries to skirt the issue
so we'll leave it at that and people can
make their own conclusions
correct i also find it interesting
that those out there we are talking
conspiracy theories right we're not
taking sides we're just
talking generally i find it interesting
that
those who consider donald trump as the
possible savior
out of this forced scenario
uh well they're saying
that he's got it under control
it's interesting that at the news
briefing
not so long ago he was quickly removed
because there was a possibility
of some danger from a shooter outside
and there are those who are saying that
he will go underground because
in the past he said that he was going to
go underground so
are there moves a foot there i mean the
conspiracy theorists
are having a field day and he's of
course against the protests and says he
will bring in
you know the federal government to sort
it out and then you have this other
faction
they seem to be in playing this double
game right
rubbing up against each other so let's
have a look at
what he has to say
well the rebate that i'm doing cuts out
the middleman and reduces costs
and the money goes back to the people
purchasing the drugs
so i have a lot of enemies out there
this may be the last time you'll see me
for a while
a lot of very very rich enemies but they
are not happy with what i'm doing
but i figure we have one chance to do it
and no other president is going to do
what i do
no other president would do a favored
nations
a rebate a buy from other nations at
much less cost
nobody and there are a lot of unhappy
people
the s p 500 and the dow dow jones are
going to be i mean the way they're going
it looks like they're just about going
to be topping records hopefully soon
excuse me
it might not have had anything to do
with me it might have been something
else but uh
it was on the outside of the premises
the wall the
the as you know the fencing especially
the new fencing that they put up is
very powerful but it was on the outside
of the white house okay and
they'll have a full report secret
service in a little while we'll have a
full report
do i see him rattled it's uh unfortunate
that this is
a world but the world's always been
a dangerous place it's not something
that's unique
the world has been you look back over
the
centuries the world has been a dangerous
place very dangerous place and
it will continue i guess for a period of
time
now if we consider our discussion king
of the north against king of the south
we have two ideologies clashing here
yes but we also read that fascinating
verse they
sit at it's in the same table and they
sit at the same table
and this is always interesting to me so
conspiracy theory or no conspiracy
theory
what does the bible say and where is all
of this heading
let us go to that web page from the
world economic forum
and see what they have to say now this
is not conspiracy
no this is their web
where do they want to take humanity
whether they are successful in this
whether this
is a conjecture or a hope
whether this is going to be a reality
that's not our place here right
this is not conspiracy for all those who
want to shout
conspiracy this is a fact
now we went through this web page
yes in some detail right it you can get
lost and
continue for a long time on this web
page especially this
integrated map yes that they've got
there on the covet 19.
they call it the covet 19 transformation
map now this map
is is very interesting and there are so
many cross links that you can go to
and we looked at them and they're
fascinating
yes now with my old eyes
i can hardly see what's on the screen
there because there's so much
information
so when you run us through it if you get
to the
integra uh transformation map this is
the first thing you'll see
right around this whole map there's
different
um headlines now this is unfortunately
not going to be integrated now
because we are this is just a slide so
then if you go
and you press for instance you click on
there
it opens up a whole map
of blue lines that links different
headlines and then you can go and click
on the headline again and see all this
if you go on each one probably if you uh
subscribe it to this or then you can
get all the information going more
detail yeah so we didn't do that but
we can still show you enough on that
map they will see different deadlines
here as well and what was interesting
is this finder vaccine one if you click
that then it shows you the different
maps
and then they have a description here of
it
and we're not going to go through all of
this i just want to show
what was interesting if you just follow
a few of these
mapping so this is their this is their
master plan
this is where they're heading and all of
this is you can also see this is not
a website or a map that's been
thought up overnight no this is there's
a lot of detail there's a lot of
information in the data but they also
tell you where they get the information
which sometimes it's universities and
all sorts of
very prominent sources
so then if you go then on that one
we clicked on that one biotechnology
so it opens it up like this then and
then
under biotechnology there's these
settings and just look at these
interesting headlines gene and genome
engineering
yes and medical biotechnology
yes environmental biotechnology
agricultural biotechnology
industrial biotechnology and then
under this one it opens the map and it
goes to
global health and then this one was very
interesting
human enhancement yes to enhance the
human being
yes so we'll go to that in a moment
but first i want to go to the
gene and genome engineering and there
was also an interesting one here
called space and under the space there's
space conflict
now i'm going through this rather
quickly but
like i said this can keep you busy for
hours
and then under space there's one
artificial intelligence and robotics
and if you go into that one then it
starts getting interesting
intelligence augmentation but they see
again
human enhancement so
it shows you it's in many many years sub
categories so you've got space space
conflict
linked with artificial intelligence
intelligence and robotics
and then there's also again human
enhancement so they link all these
things together human enhancement
i found particularly fascinating exactly
if you look
then at the sub menus under human
enhancement
you can see that you know longevity
humanness and autonomy equity and social
justice
can you imagine a term humanness and
autonomy that is an
incredible thing uh when are you
autonomous as a human when you are an
individual right
correct but what if you are subject to
the common good
must your autonomy then be curtailed
for the sake of humanity well what did
we
read in the jesuits as we said right
it would have to be curtailed but
continue it gets
fascinating enhanced genes enhanced
bodies
enhanced minds so yeah
that is that map and now i can give it
over to you again
and then also interesting to
if you go and do a little bit of
research so
is this just on their map or is
there is there already is the technology
already available
are they working on it here's a very
interesting article it's a scientific
article it's a publication it's from the
u.s national library of
medicine national institute of health
and they talk about nanoparticles
and the effect they can have on the
human genome
in the future if you think it's a bit
small but the headline there reads
non-viral gene transfection
nanoparticles
yes absolutely so it's about
nanoparticles now let's just
enlarge the abstract so we can see what
it says
the introduction here says gene therapy
the treatment or prevention of disease
by
gene transfer is regarded by many as a
potential revolution
in medicine the recently concluded human
genome project has substantially
increased our knowledge
of the molecular mechanisms of cancer
and other gene-based diseases in
addition
there are genes that have been
identified whose function in a living
organism currently remain
unknown those are largely controlling
genes
concurrently changes in the number of
genes were found to be associated with a
variety of disorders
some of which have been identified as
responsible for the onset
of several human diseases the
application of gene therapy
in the suppression or replacement of
malfunctioning
genes promises progress in understanding
physiological roles of genes and in
treating diseases
at the genetic level the non-viral
gene transfer method will permit
targeting and
analyzing biological effects to specific
cell
tissues ultimately gene therapy will
translate into substantial
improvements in therapeutic ratio and
cure rate
for a broad range of diseases which are
presently
untreatable or poorly managed now these
nanoparticles are non-viral
they are silica based and they contain
information
which directly affect the genes now
they're talking about disease here
but we've seen videos in the series
where we talked about them
where they actually also can alter the
genetics of your
mind and even the genetics of your
religious
discernment center so that you
you wouldn't if you were a
fundamentalist
be able to believe what you believed
before because they could suppress
your genetic system yes now how far
along the line
are they in terms of
interfering with your mind so that they
can actually
not only modify it enhancements
they call it but actually
regulate it now that's interesting
correct
now when we look at the conspiracy
theories out there we have to
make a point conspiracy theories they're
saying this vaccine could contain
nanoparticles this is interesting right
yes
and that these nanoparticles would then
sort of create a grid whereby
they can actually control you via
certain radiation particularly 5g
comes to mind etc that's the mindset up
there now
we're not going along with that we're
just saying that's the way it is
but the world economic forum web page
clearly indicates that they want to go
that direction yes
human enhancement control of human
thinking
control of what you do how you do it etc
just to go a little bit further here's
the the
neuro link project and this comes from
cold spring harbor laboratory an
integrated
brain machine interface platform with
thousands of
channels and this is of course
elon musk and his neural link technology
that he's been talking about this is
fascinating
stuff yes very interesting here's an
abstract from this article
brain machine interfaces hold promise
for the restoration
of sensory and motor function and the
treatment of neurological
disorders could it affect the way you
think
but clinical bmis have not yet been
widely adopted in part because
modest channel counts have limited their
potential in this
white paper we describe neuralink's
first steps towards a scalable
high bandwidth bmi system
we have built arrays of small and
flexible
electrode threads with as many as 3072
electrodes per array distributed across
96 threads we've also built a
neurosurgical
robot capable of inserting six threads
192 electrodes per minute
and each thread can be individually
inserted into the brain with
micron precision for avoidance of
surface
vasculature and targeting specific brain
regions so they can target specific
brain regions
now of course they're they're telling
you that this is all
for medicinal purposes and this all
sounds wonderful
and people that are paraplegics will be
able to walk
people that are blind where the optic
nerve is damaged will be able to see
because this technology will take over
but it goes further yes they're even
saying
that you will be able to communicate
almost
telepathically without speaking
now we conjectured in a previous one
that the
the world that is out there the angelic
world
used to be able to connect mind to mind
so the the human being was also created
with a tremendous capacity
which has somehow been curtailed as a
consequence of sin
and the devil knows this yes and
he might be wanting to bring you back to
where
this technology overwhelms you and you
think this is the greatest thing but at
the same time he wants to control you
so let's just go into this a little bit
further
here's a video which shows us what these
people
are actually doing at the moment
if someone ultimately does get a neural
link installed what will take place
well for version one of the device it
would be um
it basically implanted in your skull
it can interface basically anywhere in
anywhere in your brain
um so it could be something that you
know helps cure say
eyesight like give you returns your
eyesight even if you've like lost your
optic nerve type of thing
uh really yeah yeah absolutely hearing
obviously um i mean pretty much anything
that where that it could in principle
fix almost anything that is wrong with
the brain that's like a microcontroller
uh near muscle groups uh you you could
then create a
sort of a neural shunt that restores
somebody who is a quadriplegic to full
functionality
like they can walk around be normal whoa
yeah so maybe slightly better slightly
better
over time yes you're gonna have to cut
the whole top of someone's head off
and put a new top with a whole bunch of
wires if you want to get
you know the real turbocharged version
the p100d of brain stimulation
i mean ultimately if you if you want to
go with full
ai symbiosis you'll probably
want to do something like that symbiosis
is a scary word when it comes to ai
it's optional
i would hope so yeah it's just i mean
once you enjoy the dr manhattan
lifestyle
once you once you become a god seems
very very unlikely you're going to want
to go back to being stupid again
i mean you literally could fundamentally
change the way
human beings interface with each other
yes
yes you wouldn't need to talk well
you'll be able to interface with each
other in some sort of a non-verbal
non-physical way where you will transfer
data back and forth to each other
without having to actually use your
mouth
and make noises yeah exactly so i've
said is like
that there could be potentially a
universal language
that's created through computers that
particularly young
kids would pick up very quickly yeah i
think
you would in principle you would be able
to communicate
uh very quickly
and with far more precision
ideas and language
would i'm not sure what would happen to
language
but you could probably within a
situation like this that you would be
able to just it would be like kind of
like the matrix you you want to speak a
different language in a problem
right that's why it was downloaded the
program
so you can download the program what
programs do they want to
download into your mind
now god communicates
with humanity through the frontal lobe
and anything that impacts the frontal
lobe
impacts your decision-making capacity
don't you think the devil would like to
have control over your frontal lobe
what has he been using to date to
get rid of the efficiency of your
frontal lobe
television television music drugs
music stimulants
caffeine any one of those
cannabinoids any one of those
anything to get your frontal lobe to be
curtailed so that he can implant his way
of thinking and if that spirituality
center could be affected that would be
the ultimate that would cut out god
right yeah like he mentioned
we just download the program or and if
you become like
a god you become like a demon
demon god so those
those centers that you used to have in
the antediluvian world
that god had to curtail because of sin
because if you could read somebody's
mind
can you imagine the chaos that that
would create
and how it would increase sin
in this world true so
god eliminated that capacity
so that it would not create
a worse situation than we already have
what about the anti-diluvian world it
must
they that's probably one of the reasons
why god had to
get wiped absolutely and after the fall
there was a genetic uh switch
certain things changed
the plants changed the animals changed
their diets changed
and all of these issues but let's
continue because we are busy
with a very important thing yes
they are saying that they can change
humanity here's a statement from the
spirit of prophecy
it comes from letter 114 1903
satan uses influence of mind and mind
cast out of heaven satan set up his
kingdom in this world and ever since he
has been
untiring striving to seduce human beings
from their allegiance to god
that's his aim he uses the same power
that he used in heaven the influence of
mind
on mind that would include things like
suggestion that would include
things like hypnosis he
used these techniques now what if he can
step it up what if through nanoparticles
he could step up the control over the
human mind
men become tempters of their fellow men
the strong corrupting sentiments of
satan are cherished and they exist
deserve a masterly compelling power
and the influence of these sentiments
meant bind up with one another in
confederacies
and trade unions and secret societies
there are at work in the world agencies
that god will not much longer
tolerate any secret society
must have a secret agenda yes a buddy
agenda
right and if it is supposed to be
universally effective then that agenda
must somehow
be transferred to humanity
so this is the way he works so stay away
from any of such associations come
out of babylon now
i put the slide in because i just wanted
to show
that the jesuit mindset
is one mindset that
has to be according to their philosophy
transferred to
all of humanity and we discussed the
jesuit mindset in quite some detail
and we discussed this aspect that
they have to control your thinking
that you have to give up your
individuality for the sake of the common
good
that you have to give up your individual
judgment
to the hierarchy of the church
because according to them and
particularly the pope
has a much better understanding that you
as an individual could ever have
so he will tell you what to believe he
will tell you
what to believe and how to interpret the
bible according to his way
and god is cut out of the equation do
you think god
likes that kind of philosophy no
definitely not
did god die for your
freedom of choice absolutely if god
could have created us
without a freedom of choice then we
would not have sinned
correct then he would not have had to
die yes
so if he had this mindset
then you would not have had to die and
there would have been no sin in the
world
but you would have been a robot yes
would you like to be a robot no
would you like to have a thousand
nanoparticles and wires in your head
telling you what to do and how to
react and what to believe no
you wouldn't like that no not at all
so who would you rather trust god god
or the devil would you rather trust god
who demonstrated to
all of humanity that he values
your freedom of choice to the point
of paying the ultimate price
i mean it's a no-brainer correct as far
as i'm concerned
that's dependent on your view of god
because your view of god should be he
was loving
to do that all this yes does god have
rules yes
would god like you to obey his rules yes
he's going to force you
no he can see in humanity that he
certainly doesn't force them right
but once they've made their choice that
they do not want to adhere
to a set of logical
love imbued laws laws
then he says well then you you can't be
with me so the association of jesuit
colleges and universities
just tells us how many universities
the jesuits have in the united states
alone we're not even talking worldwide
right
27 universities and all of these
sentences for
career enhancement and
guidance and then of course after 50
years
the thing the living spirit of vatican
ii and how the jesuit education is
working in the world
now this is just colleges and
universities
and schools hundreds of schools of
course
and this mindset has to be this vatican
ii
mindset has to be transferred to the
whole of humanity
now who ran vatican ii who was behind it
the jesuits yes
who ran the first vatican council which
was the council of trent
jesus the jesuits i mean this is their
mindset
and then they still boast if you go to
the jesuit alumni in congress they'll
tell you that the united
senate state senate has 12
alumni from the jesuit universities and
the house of representatives 43 they're
pretty interested in politics right yes
and they're pretty adamant as to
what the results should be and the
movements should be about
covert and their alumni like foresee
seem to be you know very in tune with
their agenda
here's another statement from
manuscripts release number eight
god's presentation of the detestable
works of the inhabitants of the ruling
powers of the world
who bind themselves in secret societies
and confederacies
not honoring the law of god should
enable the people who have the light of
truth to keep clear
of all these evils
and more will all false religionists of
the world
manifest their evil doings for there are
but
two parties those who keep the
commandments of god and those who war
against god's holy law
but there seem to be hundreds of parties
out there yes
there's only one that says the
commandments of god
not the commandments of wrong the
so if there are only two categories then
all those other categories must be one
collective category sitting at one table
yes fascinating
and god will not much longer tolerate
this
and god will destroy the entire system
so whether the king of the north wins
or whether the king of the south wins is
irrelevant
correct they're going to be destroyed
yes
well we do know that the king of the
north is going to
have the ascendancy now let's go back to
the french
era and the french revolution and
revelation
chapter 11 who was
ruling in france
and in the entire europe for that matter
before the french revolution the roman
the roman catholic church right under
the jesuits and then they lost
a lot of their power through
protestantism
and the protestant nations were well at
least half of germany
the united kingdom the united states of
america
and then the other spatterings around
the world australia new zealand southern
africa
etc etc and somehow
they had lost their power and then they
had to regain their power
so how about throwing all religion out
both protestant and catholic and bring
in
secularism on a grand scale under a
jesuit plot
pretend that catholicism had a mortal
wound
it seemed to have a mortal wound see it
had a mortal wound
and then once the outplay of this
philosophy
has brought the world to the chaos that
we have now
bring back yes the first system is that
a possibility
yes well that's how the plan
should play out correct now in the first
instance how did rome control
humanity so that the mindset of humanity
would be absolutely in harmony with the
mindset of wrong it took away the bible
took away the bible number one secondly
free choice free choice they forced you
and if you didn't believe like they
believed the stake
torture the wreck heretic all right
now today we're saying you know that's
barbaric so
we won't torture to death or the french
revolution use the guillotine
and just chopped your head off which was
probably
not their plan a but
became their plan b and so god is going
to destroy
all of these systems so that's important
to know yes
so what is your only safety god
god that's your only safety so here are
they
that keep the commandments of god and
have the faith of jesus what does
revelation chapter 22 tell us who has
access to the tree of life
those that keep the commandments those
that keep the commandments of god unless
of course you have a modern translation
then you only have to wash your
shoulders
yeah and it doesn't even say in the
blood of the lamb
so let's stick to one that says it as it
as it is so god is going to destroy
everything that stone is going to strike
and the whole system will be taken away
now this is something i put
in writing so that we could think about
it
if you think this is a step forward for
humanity
speaking about this human enhancement
and it does not rob you of your freedom
of choice
then you have no understanding of the
character of god who was prepared to die
for your freedom of choice
can we improve on god's creation
no you know just in just
look at any issue look at the
manipulation
of food for example
genetic manipulation oh we have such
wonderful yields now yes
and you know everything is just perfect
for
packaging and distributing but
the quality is just absolutely
horrendous in many cases now just
cast your mind back to the biblical
times
when those spies went into
israel yes went into the promised land
and they came back what did they bring
back wonderful food
wonderful food and they brought back one
bunch of grapes
and how many people carried it two two
people carried this
so have we gone forward or have we gone
backwards
definitely backwards i haven't seen a
a bunch of grapes yet that two people
have to carry yeah well i was on a farm
when i was younger and there was a farm
in the cape
there was a wine farm and
there i saw a bunch of grapes which was
probably about this big okay and it
amazed me it was just one huge
bunch one one bunch of grapes so
today that is virtually impossible
they're all about this size if they're
if they're anything
wonderful so have we really gone
forwards or have we gone backwards i
mean
we spoke about heirloom seeds and
original things and those
those tomatoes that you get and that
fruit that you get
i don't know i don't think you can
improve on anything that god made
those big cabbages and everything is
when it's natural
sure if things have gone wrong and sin
has brought
demise and disease into the world you
can improve upon these things but your
freedom of choice
is what it's all about peace on earth by
transforming
humanity into zombies or peace on earth
by accepting god's plan of obedience to
his commandments by choice which one do
you want
which one of those two i'll take the
peace on earth accepting god's plan of
obedience okay do you think humanity
will by choice
except to obey god as a whole
i doubt it right
so only those who actually accept it
will be acceptable to god now there are
many that are putting their hope if you
look at these conspiracy theories out
there
and the people that talk about them in
particular they're saying
this is a sign that the church is going
to be raptured
there's no such thing in the bible there
will
only be a final separation of the wicked
and the just
and god's people will be taken
and meet the lord in the air right at
the end
after the plagues have fallen so this is
a false hope being given to the world
out there
so is god evil if he destroys this
system
or is he a loving god that's my question
i think he's a loving god well
i would be incredibly grateful
if god would prevent someone from
controlling my mind
and if he wants to do it by force or by
whatever means
i would be very grateful if god
intervenes
so joshua 24 15 says and if it seems
evil unto you to
serve the lord choose ye this day
whom you will serve that's very
important your freedom of choice
so i don't believe that god
will permit humanity to go
to that point where they control
people he might permit some that have
already given themselves over
to be controlled but humanity as a
as a as a whole i have serious doubts
get back to revelation chapter 11
verse 12 we did the other ones in the
previous chapter
and they heard a great voice from heaven
saying unto them
come up hither and they ascended up to
heaven in a cloud and their enemies
beheld them
i call this a loud cry
so the old and the new testament the
word of god
even though it was suppressed in the
french revolution in a literal sense
and then in an anti-typical sense in the
whole of humanity which we have been
dealing with in this
course then they will be
lifted up again and there will be a loud
cry
excuse me mankind
take a look at god's word make a choice
either you fall under the system of
coercion
and human enhancement
or the other
yes that's your choice and at the same
hour was there a great earthquake and a
tenth
part of the city and the
in the earthquake was slain of men
seven thousand and the remnant were
afrighted
and gave glory to god of heaven
that was typical at that stage in the
french revolution
blood all over beheading
of kings and queens and noblemen
and a destruction
of the thinking
people in an entire society
what a terrible situation occurred
and it is equated with a earthquake
so this is a reference to when they
literally
banned the bible and the french
revolution took place but
anti-typically we are going to
find similar circumstances
in other words there will be an
earth-shattering earthquaking
event which emulates
what happened in the french revolution
and we've seen it we've had the slides
on the screen
but the good news is there will be a
remnant
that will see the things that are
happening in the world
and they will give glory to god so there
will come a separation
those that choose god's way and those
that go the way
of humanity and the second woe is past
and behold the third woe
cometh quickly and then comes the
seventh trumpet
this is the heading here and the seventh
angel
sounded and there was a great voice in
heaven saying the kingdom of this world
will become the kingdoms of our lord and
of his christ
and he shall reign forever and ever and
the four and twenty elders which sat
before god and their seats fell upon
their faces and worshiped god
so here is the final culmination so what
happened there
in miniature in a local capacity
will happen universally we are in that
phase right now and then when probation
closes
the trumpet will sound and what was
a fractional slaying of men
over here referring to 7
000 which is the number of god the
number of completeness the number that
god permitted
there will be a universal destruction of
the entire humanity
that's what it says yes verse 17
says saying we give thee thanks oh lord
god almighty which
art and wasp and ought to come because
that has taken to thee thy great power
and has reigned so god has
permitted these things to this point
and when probation closes and the
plagues fall
humanity is destroyed in the final
plague
when that hail falls and that mighty
earthquake comes
all of humanity is destroyed
and god's people will be taken away not
before then
as some of them say now go through it
they have to go through it
remember that literal israel was the
type
they went through the plagues yep
anti-typical israel
will go through the plagues and will be
taken away
and all the promises in the bible apply
to this time
a thousand will fall by your side ten
thousand
by your right hand it'll not come down
and this is after
the close of probation after the close
of probation before the close
it's interesting we'll have turmoil
and what happens to the nations they
were angry
and thy wrath is come and the time of
the dead that they should be judged
and that thou should give reward unto
thy servants the prophets and to the
saints and them that fear thy name
small and great and should destroy them
which destroy the earth
so there will be a destruction and there
will be a redemption
you have to choose yes and the temple of
god this is fascinating
was opened in heaven so you get a vision
humanity gets a vision
of the temple and god of god and what do
they see inside this temple
and they were seen in his temple the ark
of the testament
that's the ten commandments the law of
god
you have replaced it with human rights
under jesuit
philosophy french revolution philosophy
the whole world has adopted human rights
as opposed to god's commandments
jesuit philosophy and now
they see this is the standard of
righteousness
yes and there was lightning and voices
and thunderings and earthquake
and that final plague of hail total
destruction
50 kilograms in some
measurements others slightly less
depending what measure you take for a
talent
but that is a huge
destruction with rapid steps we are
approaching this period
when protestant churches shall unite
with the secular power
to sustain a false religion
for opposing which their ancestors
endured the fiercest persecution
then will the papal sabbath be enforced
by the combined authority of church and
state
there will be a national apostasy which
will end
only in national ruin now we've
discussed national run we've looked at
population reductions that can only be
national run
justin explain what is national apostasy
national apostasy is when the whole
nation
decides to follow the precepts
of a power that is not biblical
that's national apostasy even if it
looks biblical even if it looks good
so if rome says i have an authority and
i have the law
and not god and you will listen to my
authority and not god's authority
then they've thrown down the gauntlet
and humanity has to make a decision
with whose authority are they going to
run
and that national apostasy will be
the government of the country enforcing
a religious precept that is not biblical
and then comes national rule now let's
have a look whether donald trump
is saying that the churches should side
with
with him and the government i find this
this interplay at the moment between the
king of the north philosophy and the
king of the south philosophy
very interesting so let's just look at
what he has to say
a lot of things shut down including
churches let's talk about that the
importance of reopening churches i know
you've talked about that
i think they should open the churches
it's up to the governors but i think and
i'm recommending it you open the
churches
they'll spread they'll be socially
spread they'll have masks
and they'll do what they have to do you
know the hygiene and everything else
that we know it's a very simple list
but i think it's very unfair that they
have i saw jim jordan the other day
talking about it very well that they
have
50 000 people protesting and they're
standing on top of each other
practically and yet you're not allowed
to go to church you don't go to schools
we want to open our churches we want to
open our schools
but they have to let the churches open
they want to put i mean tell you the the
democrats want to put them out of
business they want to put the churches
out of business
mr president is there a way to deem
churches as essential businesses how do
we do that
i am looking at that because i think
it's enough already you have some states
i think they have no they never want
them open they don't want churches open
look
the democrats frankly uh if you look at
the radical left democrats which are
radical left now they've gone radical
left
whether you're talking about life or
whether you're talking about almost
anything
they're not liking it they're not liking
it and if there was one message you
wanted to say to our viewers what would
it be right now
well i think anybody having to do with
frankly religion but certainly the
catholic church you have to be with
president trump when it comes to
pro-life when it comes to all of the
things these people are going to take
all of your rights away including second
amendment because
you know catholics like their second
amendment so
i saved the second amendment i have if i
wasn't here you wouldn't have a second
amendment
and pro-life is your big thing and
you won't be on that side of the issue i
guarantee if uh
if the radical left because you're going
to take over they're going to push him
around like he was nothing
now don't you find that fascinating
so he is the one who says the churches
should open and the churches should side
with his philosophy
particularly the roman catholic church
because their philosophy
is basically what he said his philosophy
now remember he's also a jesuit trend
i find this very interesting this is
exactly
what we see in the bible
that the mark of the beast will be
informed
now enforced enforced by
uh church state
yes conglomerate now let's say
that for argument's sake this philosophy
is the one that will turn out to be the
one wielding power
then there's a tremendous likelihood
that religious legislation
would come into play again to prevent
this chaos
out there in the world isn't that
correct
here's an article trump campaign advisor
jenna ellis separation of church and
state is a liberal lie
they definitely want church and state to
come together we don't have to read
the argument in detail
but the notion that the united states
observes the separation of church and
state is a lie
according to president donald trump's
senior campaign
legal advisor they should be together
now let's think about this now we've
been talking so much about
sabbath why would it be the sabbath
and people are saying that we are
obsessed with the sabbath
well let's think about it the sabbath
is god's mark of authority correct
and it says in exodus 31 verse 13 speak
thou
also unto the children of israel saying
verily my
sabbath you shall keep
for it is a sign between me and you
throughout your generations that you may
know that i am the lord that
does sanctify you
it is the mark of his
authority
and the roman catholic church says that
the
sunday is a mark of her
ecclesiastical authority
so more than any other idea
or commandment the sunday is linked
to the authority of rome
and the sabbath is linked to the
authority
of god so when it comes to a
choice whose authority
is the one that i accept in my life
if the sign is the sabbath or the sunday
then the keeping of the one or the other
determines where your allegiance lies
so to me it's not a question of a day
people always say oh it's just a day
it's not a question of a day it's a
question of authority
which happens to be absolutely
linked with the day
so if i want to show the world that
i accept in my life the authority
of god over that of anyone else
what do i have to do to display it to
the world
keep sabbath yes can satan
attack any of the other commandments
well he has he's made them all
null and void but the very last one that
he is
keeping in reserve is the sabbath issue
and he has no choice but to attack the
sabbath
why you can explain it because it's the
authority of god
and if he wants to attack the authority
of god
he can do all the other things he can he
can send 10
000 musicians into a stadium
singing highway we're on a highway to
hell and we don't care
that doesn't attack the authority of god
it's linked to the sabbath
so he has to attack the sabbath and he
has to
replace it with the mark of his
authority
there is no choice he doesn't have a
choice on on the sound no
if he wants to attack the authority he
has to attack the sabbath
and that's going to be the issue whether
people like it
or not that is the issue because it's
linked
to the authority so
we were told also that this links up
with revelation chapter
18. yes so we will not go into such
detail because revelation
11 is basically the type
of this anti-typical event that one
gave a local application with a
greater application universally
and this one revelation chapter 18 will
give the consequences so let's just
briefly go
through it we've dealt with it in so
much detail we don't have to
go into all the issues in the beginning
here because we've had
what's ups on all of this yes and after
these things i saw another angel come
down from heaven this is
after the mark of the beast and
revelation
13 and then there is this
message of tremendous glory going to the
world
and he cried mightily with a strong
voice so this is the loud cry
saying babylon the great is fallen has
fallen and it's become a habitation of
devils and a
hold of every foul spirit in a cage of
every unclean and hateful
bird so we've discussed babylon
the conglomerate of churches
under the leadership of rome we
discussed the three
parts of it that it was the dragon the
beast and the false prophet we're not
going to go into this detail
and that the the foul spirit was a false
holy spirit
that permeated the systems and then it
tells us that all the nations drank of
this
false doctrine this false wine
of the wrath of her fornication in other
words
apostasy towards god
and even the kings of the earth had
committed fornication with her
so the kings of the earth are
fraternizing with the babylonian
religious system under the leadership of
the papacy
and we just saw it yeah we just saw it
in the video
and the merchants of the earth waxed
rich through the abundance of her
delicacies
well look at the merchants of the world
all the mega
billionaires and whether they're playing
the left fiddle or whether they're
playing the right fiddle whether their
name is gates or whether their name is
soros it doesn't really matter right
and there are so many conspiracy
theories about this this is their game
the fact of the matter is they have the
economies in their in their hand can
they shut it down overnight
yes they can shut the economies of the
world down overnight
do they have them in their hand then yes
do they seem to particularly care that
they've been
shutting it down no it doesn't look as
if they're too bothered right no
no so the individual and some of the
it says the merchants will wax rich so
some of these
even got richer when the economies did
shut down ah
we actually saw that right and i had
another voice from heaven saying come
out of her my
people that you be not partakers of her
sins and that you receive not of her
plagues
if you're part of the system you're
going to receive the plagues
and this idea that
the protestant world will be raptured
that idea is going to rupture pretty
soon it's not going to happen
it's not going to happen for our sins
i've reached unto heaven
what is sin the transgression of the law
absolutely and god has remembered the
iniquity so
revelation chapter 11 what was the
standard that god showed at the end
there
the commandments the commandments of god
reward her even as she rewarded you and
double under her double according to her
works in the cup which she has
filled full to her double
so retribution is coming
how much she has glorified herself and
lived deliciously
so much torment and sorrow giver
for she says in her heart i sit as queen
and am not a widow
and shall not see sorrow
she believes that she has everything
under control
she is the mother church she's going to
glorify herself it's fascinating they
get away with everything yeah
and the bishops are saying or even if
the priests confess that they have been
pedophiles and that they've done this or
that on the other
the system of the church does not permit
us to
to tell others about it or bring them to
justice
and they sit in all of this luxury
wrapped in gold and all of these things
therefore shall our plagues come in one
day death and mourning and famine
all of those we will see terrible things
on this earth
yes we are living in a time of crisis
and she shall be utterly burned with
fire for strong as the lord god who
judges her
so she is a priestly prostitute because
she's going to be burnt with fire
a normal prostitute just gets stoned
right
so we know this is a religious system
that's going to be
destroyed and what all the kings of the
earth do
when they see that the religious system
has let them down how will they know
the plagues yes absolutely
first of all the cities went there was
turmoil there was death everywhere
millions of people dying and they're
saying we have to get back to god
and we'll keep the sunday and we'll
enforce the precepts of the church
and then the plagues fall
and they will realize that they've been
deceived
and what will they say the kings of the
earth who have committed fornication and
lived deliciously with their shall
bewail her
and lament for her when they see the
smoke of her burning
the people will turn against these
churches and against this babylonian
system and says
you you said that these people that were
warning us
and telling us to keep the commandments
of god and not to keep the precepts of
men were fanatics
and now look at us we're dying like
flies
there's famine destruction all around us
and they will turn upon these
false shepherds and just as you had in
the old testament times
when people the enemies of god destroyed
themselves so they will destroy
themselves
standing afar off for the fear of
atonement
so were they far off in the beginning
no they were in union and now all of a
sudden when they see the consequences
oh but it's too late it's too late
it's too late it's sort of like when
noah went into the ark
yes and the door was shut and then
afterwards when it started raining
a lot of people probably then also
thought if only if only
if only alas alas that great city
babylon that
mighty city for in one hour is thy
judgment come and the merchants of the
earth shall weep and mourn over a
well imagine if these multi-billionaires
or suddenly paupers right they will weep
for no man buyeth their merchandise
anymore i think
google might go out of business to think
so
and at that stage it doesn't matter
anymore because
there won't be evangelism when the
plagues fall
there's no need because the probation is
closed
the merchandise of gold and silver and
nano particles and
no we mustn't add to the word silver
precious stones pearls fine linen purple
sink silk scarlet and all vine
wood and all manner vessels of ivory and
all manner vessels of most precious
wooden of brass and iron and marble just
talking about merchandise in general
and cinnamon and odours and ointments
and frankincense and wine and oil
and wheat and beasts and sheep and
horses and chariots
and the fruit that thy soul lusted after
are departed from thee
it's interesting that it talks about
lust
lusted after this craving of humanity
and all things which were dainty and
goodly are departed from thee and thou
shalt find them
no more at all total destruction yes
is coming the merchants of these things
which were made
rich by her shall stand far off for the
fear of her torment
weeping and wailing does that speak
about a total collapse of the
of the economy yes yes
now it's interesting that deagle uh
portrayed a partial collapse yes
but here we have a total total collapse
so is deagle or is that maybe referring
to a little bit different time
it's a little time of trouble and then
comes the greater time of trouble
so we are now in the little time of
trouble until
probation closes then we go to total
destruction when the
plagues begin so revelation 18 gives you
a broader picture of the
final destruction and the only way
to avoid it is come out of her
my people and who are his people those
that keep the commandments of
god and have the testimony of jesus
and the faith of jesus and keep the
commandments that they may have the
right to the tree of life
how much plainer can god put it
i don't know i don't know and then also
what i would like to add is
that there's still hope
up until the close of probation
absolutely
after that then this is what will happen
there's no
there's no more hope now listen to verse
16 and saying alas alas that great city
that was clothed in
fine linen purple scarlet
decked with gold precious stones and
pearls which church
has those as its particular colors
roman catholic roman catholic church
reason that's the
yeah the age of reason jesuit thinking
for in one hour so great riches has come
to norton every shipmaster
and all the company in ships and sailors
and as many as trade by sea
stood afar of total collapse of the
world
economy not partial
and cried when they saw the smoke of a
burning saying
what city is like unto this great city
it controlled the world
it controlled the monetary system didn't
um
nebuchadnezzar asked the same he asked
the same
questions and they control both sides
this is the terrible thing they control
both sides
and they sit at one table and they plan
this
thesis antithesis synthesis
back to obedience to the king of the
north
destruction
and they cast dust on their heads and
cried weeping and wailing saying alas
alas that great city
wherein were made rich all that had
ships in the sea by
reason of her costliness for in one hour
she made
desolate how do you get to the top
in merchandise and in trade
you have to be part of the system yes is
it perhaps useful to be part of their
secret societies
rejoice over her though thou heaven
and the holy apostles and prophets for
god has
avenged you on her that's the other side
of the coin
i will rejoice a system that wants to
rob you of your personal
choice may god fulfill
this promise but may as many as possible
heed the warning and a mighty angel
took up a stone like a great millstone
and cast it into the sea
that's the nations saying
thus with violence shall that great city
babylon be thrown down and shall be
found
no more at all total elimination
i do not want to be part of the
economical movement
no because you're part of babylon yes
and the voice of the harper and the
musician and the pipers and the trumpet
trumpeters shall be heard no more at all
in the and no craftsman
whatsoever crafty shall be shall be
found
any more in thee all those great
cathedrals all those
masons they're all going to be gone
and the sound of a millstone shall be
heard no more indeed this is interesting
because the millstone in this
scenario is the one that grinds wheat
it's the one that feeds the people
doctrine the bread of of life but this
is a false bread
this false millstone will disappear
because they have set aside the bread of
life
for saints and relics and
systems which have no salvation in them
and the light of a candle shall shine no
more at all in thee and the voice of the
bridegroom and the bride
shall be heard no more at all in thee
for thy merchants
were the great men of the earth
all those monuments with these great men
of the earth and those that we honor
with special days
i'm afraid they will not be
in that list that is
mentioned up there that will be
rejoicing
for by thy sorceries were all nations
deceived this is direct demonic
intervention and in her was found the
blood of the prophets and of the saints
and of all that was slain upon the earth
they were responsible for these things
many of the wicked were greatly enraged
as they suffered the effects of the
plagues
this comes from early writings
it was a scene of fearful agony parents
were bitterly reproaching their children
and children their parents brothers
their sisters and sisters their brothers
loud wilding cries were heard in every
direction
it was you who kept me from receiving
the truth
which would have saved me from this
awful hour
the people turned upon their ministers
with bitter hate and reproached them
saying
you have not warned us you told us that
all the world was to be converted and
cried peace peace
to quiet every fear that was aroused
perhaps we can add there you told us
that we would be raptured and not be
part of this but it won't happen
you have not told us of this hour and
those who want us of it you declared to
be fanatics and evil men who would ruin
us
but i saw that the ministers did not
escape the wrath of god
their suffering was tenfold greater than
that of their people
i believe there are many in babylon many
ministers in babylon who will see the
light
yes i believe that many in babylon will
come out and heed that cry come
out of her my people and this is an
appeal
to all the ministers in all the
denominations out there
listen to the word of god it's not
complicated
keep the commandments of god and hold to
the faith of jesus
the protestant world today see in the
little company keeping the sabbath a
martha kai in the gate
you have to get rid of him his character
and conduct expressing
reverence for the law of god are a
constant rebuke to those who have cast
off the fear of the lord and are
trampling upon his sabbath
the unwelcome intruder must by some
means be put
out of the way this is the aim of the
devil now that irritating little cult
that irritating little cult when the
power invested in kings is allied to
goodness it is because
the one in responsibility is under the
divine dictation
when power is allied with wickedness it
is allied to satanic agencies and will
work to destroy
those who are the lord's property
it shouldn't be too difficult to discern
whether a ruler is sticking to the word
of god
or whether he's working contrary to the
word of god
the protestant world have set up an idol
sabbath in the place of god
sabbath should be and they are treading
in the footsteps of the papacy for this
reason i see the necessity of the people
of god moving out of the cities into
retired country places
where they may cultivate the land and
raise their own produce
thus they may bring their children up
simple healthful
habits i see the necessity of making
haste
to get all things ready for the crisis
we are in the final moments
of earth's history the roman church has
not relinquished her claim to supremacy
we can see it yeah when the world
and the protestant churches accept the
sabbath of her creating
while they reject the bible sabbath they
virtually admit this assumption
in so doing they ignore the principle
which separates them from rome
that the bible and the bible only is the
religion of protestants
as the movement for sunday enforcement
gains favor
it will eventually bring the whole
protestant world under the banner of
rome
and then the protestant world will learn
what the purposes of
rome really are control
control control that's it
only when it is too late to escape the
snare
she's silently growing into power
not so silently anymore anymore no
doctrines are exerting their influence
in legislative halls and in churches did
we
see all those alumni
in congress and in the senate
and in the hearts of men she is
strengthening her forces to further our
own ends and when the time comes
she will strike all that she desires is
vantage ground
whoever shall believe and obey the word
of god will
incur reproach and persecution
i want to end with this verse second
corinthians 5
10 for you must all appear before the
judgment seat of christ
that everyone may receive the things
done in his body
according to that he has done whether it
be good
or bad my point with this verse is
all shall appear before the judgment
seat of christ
so that it can be determined what he has
done
in his body as well as in his mind
as to whether it is good or whether it
is bad
that means god is going to hold
everyone accountable can he hold someone
accountable
who is not capable of making a choice no
he won't can't they all right
so if you cannot make a choice
and the world economic forum is telling
us that they're going to
modify people so that
they conform will god permit it
i i cannot see that he will no i don't
see god can permit it
why not because god is going to hold
everyone accountable for their choice
so if a system takes away your freedom
of choice
on a universal scale god will have to
stop it
otherwise he cannot fulfill this promise
so i believe that the time has come when
this world is going to come to an
end and people may shout this is
fear-mongering or whatever
no i believe it's just a reality it's
common sense
humanity on every level
in terms of corruption in terms of
blatant apostasy in
terms of blatant horrendous
criminality and every single level
spiritually satanism the world has
reached the point
of no return it cannot be fixed
and i believe god is going to intervene
and may this series help people to make
a choice
make a choice either we obey god
who died for our freedom of choice
or we obey the system and we become
robots
may god help us with that choice shall
we close with prayer please
heavenly father
all that has been prophesied
has and is coming to pass
and what remains for humanity is to make
a choice
and the choice is a simple choice
a choice between the authority of god
and the authority of man a choice
between
freedom and a choice between slavery
help us to make the correct choice in
jesus name
amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you